[UPBEAT MUSIC]
- Welcome to The
Data Science
Hangout. And I hope
everybody's having a great
week. I'm Rachael. I lead
our pro community at Posit.
And if you have not
been here before,
this is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing--
and you're getting to hear
about what's going on in the
world of data, across
different industries.
So we're here every Thursday,
at the same time, same place.
So if you are somewhere
in the future,
watching this
recording on YouTube,
you can always add it to your
calendar with the details,
included below.
Together,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everyone. And we all
love to hear from everybody.
No matter your level of
experience or area of work,
it's great to hear from you.
It's also totally OK
to just listen in here.
If you don't want to join
in the conversation, that's OK too.
But there's three ways you can
jump in and ask questions or
provide your own
perspective. So you can
always jump in by raising
your hand here on Zoom.
And I'll be on the lookout.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And if you do want me to
read it out instead of you--
maybe you're in a cafe
or your dog's barking or something--
just put a little star next
to your question in the Zoom chat.
And then we also
have a Slido link,
which my colleagues
will be sharing-- oh,
Tyler just shared
it right now--
which they shared in the chat,
so you can ask questions
anonymously too.
With all that, thank you all
so much for joining us here,
on this Thursday. I'm so
excited to have Brad Weiner
here, with us, as
my co-host today.
Brad is the Chief Data Officer
at University of Colorado,
Boulder. And Brad, to
get us going, here,
I'd love to have you just jump
in and introduce yourself,
share a little bit
about your role,
and also something you like
to do outside of work, too.
- Yeah, great. So
thanks so much, Rachael.
I wanted to Thank Rachael and
everybody from the Posit team for
being here.
And I think on behalf of--
and hello, Brian, good to see you.
And then of course,
it's easy to thank the
community developers. But also,
just thanks to everyone from
the Posit team for helping us
do cool stuff in our
jobs and in our lives. So
it's super fun to get to
hang out with everyone.
My name is Brad Weiner. I
am the chief data officer, here
at the University of Colorado, Boulder.
And I got into this
role in a fairly
elliptical way. I, like
many of you, are not
technologists to start.
I was actually a
creative writing major in college.
And I will die on this hill,
that data science and technical
work is inherently creative work.
But over time,
I started working for
universities in a lot of
different roles. And at
some point along the way,
someone was like, hey, we
need someone to do some reporting.
And we need someone to do this.
And I've always
liked computers.
I've always like working with
them. So I'm like, yeah, sure,
I'll give that a shot, and
thought it was unbelievably fun
and interesting and a really
cool puzzle to
solve, and over time,
got more and more and more
engaged in the data side of
what colleges and
universities do.
There was also a
bump in the road,
where I was in graduate school,
and I took a
statistics course--
by the way, hello to
all my Minnesota pals out there.
But I was at the
University of Minnesota.
And I had a professor who
taught his statistics classes
using our-- that
was in about 2009,
that I was first introduced
to the whole concept of
open-source data science tools,
and just totally
fell in love with it,
just thought it
was the most fun,
most interesting thing
that could possibly happen.
And so that led to
the opportunity to work on a
data science team out in startup land,
and then finally, to
move here, to CU Boulder,
to lead a data science
team here, and then eventually,
become the chief data officer.
So that's a little,
tiny bit of the journey.
I like to give a
quick overview of
higher ed in general.
This is, maybe,
boring for people.
But I imagine many of you
have gone to a university somewhere
around the world. And
you've had some post-secondary education.
And universities are--
they seem like they're
like this one thing.
But what a University is,
is it's just this collection
of thousands of tiny,
little units. And there's
this famous joke that's,
we're hundreds or thousands
of little micro units,
that are all unified
by a common disagreement over
parking or a
common disagreement over the
temperatures in buildings or
a common disagreement over our
football team or whatever.
But let me just give you
a quick sense of what--
the president of the University
of California, in the
'60s, was a guy
named Clark Kerr.
And he referred to the
modern university as a multi
university. So let me just
quickly tell you why we're here.
The University of Colorado
is a research university.
We have three missions.
Our three missions are to
engage in research and to
create new knowledge
out in the world,
to teach and
pass that knowledge
on to students,
and then finally, to
engage with the public,
in what's called the
public engagement mission.
And that's translating your
research efforts into things
that can be broadly valuable.
And that really aligns
very closely with what
open-source tools do.
But we also do a lot more.
We produce art and creative
works. We act as a venue
for all kinds of things.
We're a community space.
We have a football
team. We have museums.
We have a bowling alley.
We provide health care
and patient treatment.
We, at least at CU Boulder,
put a lot of stuff
into outer space.
We engage in economic
development with the community,
here in Boulder, and
the state of Colorado,
and internationally.
We-- at least at CU,
we care and feed and
sustain a live Buffalo, named Ralphie,
who runs around on
the football field.
So the number of things
that a single university are engaged
in are quite limitless.
And so why I like to lead
with this whole spiel is that each
one of those
results in a very--
almost limitless number
of interesting data science
questions and problems.
So that's the intro.
And I definitely want to take
most of the time to answer
questions for you.
But just, if you could imagine
all of that complexity,
every single one of those components
can land as a data question.
And so why I am here and
why our teams are here is to try
and think through ways to
make the student experience better,
to make the faculty
experience better,
to make the staff
to make us work
more effectively, work more efficiently,
to make it so that the
people of Colorado have the best possible
university that they can have.
So with that--
I'm loving this
chat, by the way
- Yeah, I love that--
I love that intro too.
But we forgot one thing.
What do you like to do
outside of work, as well?
- What do I like to
do outside of work? So
recently,
I decided I needed to spend
less time in front of a screen.
And so I started
taking piano lessons,
which I encourage anyone,
especially if you're
later in life or midlife,
to just try something totally new.
I walk into these piano lessons
and the person before me is an
eight-year-old
girl, who's amazing.
And I'm
barely making it through
the treble stuff.
So I've really been
enjoying learning
to play piano and
getting back into music.
- I love that. That's awesome.
BRAD WEINER: Thanks for
that question, Rachael.
- Yeah, I just
started taking guitar
lessons a few weeks ago too,
so actually learning music
theory again after fourth-grade
flute class.
Patrick, I see you
have your hand raised,
here to jump in with a
question. You want to jump in?
- Thanks, Rachael. And
hi, everybody. And thanks, Brad,
for being here. I
appreciate your time.
First, I just want to say
I love universities too,
and their weirdness and flaws and
all the strange things about them.
But your enthusiasm for it
and the way you articulated that,
just now, was awesome.
So thank you very much.
I really enjoyed that and
appreciate how into it you are.
My question is
specific to the
university system--
if you have any examples
of where you have really
influenced an
institutional-level decision--
or maybe just for a
school or department--
but where you all have
really shaped something,
a real impact story from your
data science work for the
university.
- Yeah, that's a
great question. And so Patrick,
I'm guessing you have
experience in academia or in
higher ed. You seem to
know the space pretty well.
Doing the data work
is the easy part.
Getting people to actually use the
data and inform policies is much trickier.
And I also always like to point
to the fact that it really does
take a village. We meet all
kinds of people to be invested
and interested in
a project.
But there is one that we've
been pointing to lately,
which was just
released publicly to--
quietly because it
happened during finals.
But one of the things that
we've thought a lot about is
ways to make it so that
students have as easy of an
experience as possible
because we really, really want
students to be successful, not
just because that's our core
mission, but we're
measured on that.
All universities are measured
on that in a lot of ways.
And students want to go to
a place where they're going to be
successful. So we're
constantly looking for
what I would consider--
and I know this is
gross terminology for people in
higher ed-- but
building a college degree
really is a supply-chain
problem. You need to have
all of these constituent parts.
And they need to land
at the right time.
And there's tons
of dependencies.
And those dependencies need to
be built out years in advance.
So if we don't have
enough chemistry labs,
that student doesn't
get to take chemistry.
And if not enough students
take chemistry, they don't have the
required courses. And
they can't graduate.
So we're constantly
looking for these things.
And one of the things
that we have found
is that students found the
prices of their textbooks to
be something of a barrier.
And one of the things
that we actually found--
we're not only trying
to graduate students,
but we're trying to graduate
everybody as equitably as possible. If
the experience is one way for
some students in one way for
another group of students,
that is not considered success.
And so what we were finding,
and what we had heard
and what we had learned,
is that students were
potentially choosing which
courses to take based on
the cost of the textbooks.
And there's also a little bit
of this mode of understanding, now,
that the students of today
are used to subscription services.
Nobody ever thinks, oh,
how many songs did I
listen to on Spotify?
Am I getting my money's
Worth there just used to--
or Netflix or these models,
where you just pay one price
and you get everything.
And it doesn't matter how much you
use it or how little you use it.
So Patrick, to answer
your question--
this is the long way
around. But to answer your question,
we just recently deployed--
and you can read
about it publicly--
but one of the first handful,
maybe dozen or 15 schools,
that have gone in on this
bookstore-equity access
model, which is basically,
students pay one price.
And that gives them the
financial stability,
the predictability
in their budgets,
their ability to
budget on books,
but also the ability to be
really flexible in what they take.
And
by paying that one price,
they get what we call
day-one digital access.
And there's also evidence
that students who--
think about your college days. You
go and you take a class.
The professor gives the
old, look to your left,
look to your right, one
of you is going to fail.
And you're like,
I'm out of here.
And so then what you have
to do is, you have to go.
You have to go back
to the bookstore.
You have to return that
book. And so we have found--
and there's evidence
that having digital,
immediate access to your books
is actually a student
success lever.
And so for a
variety of reasons,
we wanted to implement
this program.
And one of the things that
we were asked to do is--
what price should
the bundle be?
And
if any of you have
worked in pricing,
it's a really complicated problem.
If the price is too high,
nobody participates. And
the whole thing collapses on
itself. And if it's too low,
you don't cover your costs.
And so we had a whole team
of people who were thinking
through that problem.
And
Rachael was very
clear. She's like,
you do not need to
shill for Posit.
But we are happy to say that
we used our super-sweet Posit
Workbench set up to simulate
a whole bunch of different
options. The Data
Science team did that.
And we were able to
help them provide--
to guide them on what that
price was. And it got deployed
out. And so next year,
from what I understand,
all undergraduates at CU Boulder
will pay $279 a semester,
and get all of their books on day one.
And if they drop a class,
then those books go away
and the new ones come in.
And they just have
access to their books.
Patrick,
I think it would be valuable to
follow up with me a year from
now and see how well we
did because this is-- it's
a known unknown. We're going to
have to see where it landed.
- That is a great
example. Thank you very much. And
really, not what
I was expecting,
in terms of the
example you choose.
But it just demonstrates how broad
the impact could be in an
area that's so complex
and diverse, like you described.
So thank you.
That is wonderful.
- Yep. You've you got it.
Sorry, I need to read the chat.
"--is less than I was paying
20 years ago." So that's-- yeah. So--
we'll
see how we do.
- Yeah, that's amazing. There's a
lot of love for that example,
in the chat here, too.
I see-- Abigail, you had
asked a question, in the chat,
a little bit earlier. Do
you want to jump in, here?
ABIGAIL: Thanks, Rachael. Yeah,
this is something multiple
organizations I've been part of
have been trying to figure
out, what to use for databases.
So I see you guys are doing a
lot of public dashboards on top of public.
How did you think that
through, an organization--
what DataBiz tools to use?
- So that is a great question.
I'm sorry, your name is
Abigail? I didn't see
where it got highlighted.
ABIGAIL: Yes.
- Awesome. So thanks
for that great question.
DataBiz is
eternally complicated
because the
technology is always moving.
And
then I think it's also fair
to point out that higher ed tends
to be a fairly
conservative industry.
And it tends to buy
things in big ways.
So hey, we want to spin up
a Posit server,
and just test it
out on 10 users,
is usually a little bit
different than, what
is the best way that we
can use our tremendous buying power to
have everybody
on the same tool?
And so
it's always striking
a balance. But
a lot of universities have
gone in pretty deep on--
I don't know if I'm allowed
to say it-- but on Tableau.
If a third of you hang up right
now, I will not blame you.
RACHAEL DEMSPEY: You can
say whatever you want.
BRAD WEINER: No, I
know. But I'm just--
so anyway,
Tableau is an industry
standard across what's called
institutional research. So
universities have all these
compliance regulations.
They need to report out
a bunch of stuff. And
so Tableau is just
pretty commonly used,
and has been for about
the last 10 years.
So we do use--
no comment, Bill, but
you're potentially correct.
But one of the
things that we're constantly thinking
through are ways to
leverage more
modern technology.
And then one of
the things that's
a really interesting problem
space is that Tableau
doesn't necessarily provide semantic
HTML underneath, as
part of its API calls.
And what that means is
that it's actually a little bit
difficult to access with
screen readers. And of course,
we're a public university. We put
out a bunch of public data.
And one of the things we want
to make sure we do is have as
accessible of
visualizations and accessible access
to our information as possible.
And so
Tableau provides a ton of
value for a lot of reasons.
And people really like being
able to explore the data.
But we are also looking at
other ways to potentially
visualize information
and put out data.
There's also just people who want
to use open-source tools. And so
there's always the
conversation of
how
big can we scale things
like Flask or Streamlit or Shiny?
And I know that those
are amazing options. And I love
them. But we haven't gotten to
a point of institution-wide buy in.
So we pick,
Abigail, in the way that
we pick a lot of things,
which is through a
process called satisficing, which is
like, well, the university
up the road is doing it.
It seems good enough.
It'll be fine.
We'll go with that.
And then we're mostly
happy with what we get
until something
better comes along.
And all of the open-source
questions, I totally agree with.
And we just haven't
gotten there yet.
So those of you who work
in your school start-up,
with 50 people, and
you're like, oh, well,
we were in Streamlit for three
weeks and it didn't work for
this, now we're going to pivot
over to Shiny or whatever,
it's just a lot harder for us
to move the gravity of such a
big organization.
And I will say Tableau has a
lot of advantages. It has a lot
of functionality, although it does
not have a spell check. So
what does that mean?
- I
see Lisa had a follow up
to your story, that you shared,
about the book pricing.
Lisa, do you want to jump in?
- Sorry. I'm
lunching right now,
which is rather early for
Minnesota. But-- so it is.
Yeah, I was just curious
if you shared out--
and maybe it's a little
too early-- any of the
findings about
the books because I
know, having been in academia,
that at least [? McAlister
?] was thinking about that
problem, as well.
- Yeah, we're still
pretty new to it.
And
higher ed,
seemingly, never has a
mythical first mover.
But there are a couple of
schools that have gone in on
this, including the University
of California at Davis.
And so they're the ones who
have the most information about it.
I would be happy to share and
talk with the people
who actually built this out.
But right now, we are
launching it for this fall.
And so it'll be a little
while before we have any real outcome
data. But of course, the
really exciting part will be,
can we measure whether
or not that particular intervention
had an impact on
student success?
And so probably a year
or two years from now,
we'll have some real data on
what it all meant. Right now,
we were just trying to get the
thing out the door and put a
price on it. But all the
cool stuff is yet to happen.
Also, hi, Lisa.
I know Lisa from--
tangentially, through the Twin
Cities data science community.
So it's good to see
my Minnesota peeps in here.
LISA: Likewise.
- I see--
oh, sorry. I see, Allen,
you had asked a question a
little bit earlier in the chat.
Do you want to
jump in here next?
- Yeah, sure. Hi, Brad.
And hey, everybody.
It's super fun today.
Brad, I'm really curious
where your role lives, within
the institution. Are you
strongly connected to IT? Are
you in administration?
And I've got to think
that where you live,
organizationally, has got to impact
on how work comes to
you, how you get to decide
what to do, how you're prioritized,
all those kinds of things. If you
can expand on that, that'd be great.
- Yeah, that's a great
question, Allen. And I work in
the administrative side.
But I have a really good--
I have a colleague who's
a chief data officer.
And he will basically say that if
you run or work with a data
organization-- and I would
probably apply this to
any of your
organizations, although I
know my industry best--
but if you are a centralized
data team, and you're not
serving everybody,
you're failing.
And maybe that's a little bit
harsh because it might not be
set up that way everywhere.
But for us, we want to support
academic units.
We want to support
academic leadership.
We want to support colleges
and schools and programs just as
much as we want to support
the auxiliary units, parking,
and the bookstore, and finance,
and budget, and enrollment,
and all of those things.
So
our role, in the most
big-picture way, is to support
students, faculty, and staff,
and to engage in those three
missions as much as we possibly
can. And parsing out where the
boundaries are is really, really tough.
So people on my
team, for instance,
we have a whole team
that does surveys.
And those surveys
help understand
how students are
engaging on campus, what
their sense of belonging is,
what type of activities
they're participating in.
But one of the things we do is,
we run what are called the
faculty course questionnaires
for all of campus.
So every time you get to the
end of semester and you get a--
this professor was
great or this professor
wasn't so great, all of
those data are publicly available,
and come through this data group.
And that provides us
opportunities to really talk
about student success through
the lens of teaching and
learning, and
through the lens of
how students are engaging in
the classroom. And then of course,
there's a whole discipline
of what's known as learning
analytics. So if
you Google that,
there's all kinds of
papers that are out there.
But the degree
to which students
in different classes
perform on different types of
exercises or different types of--
in
different types of
learning environments--
also matters. So
a bunch of years ago,
I had the opportunity to
work with a multi-institutional team
from around the Big Ten.
And we were trying to
understand whether or not
there was any difference in
academic performance based on a
student self-reported gender identity
in introductory STEM classes.
And it was really
fascinating because one,
it was an amazing data
engineering problem. You're like, well,
we have a five-hour chemistry
class and they have a
three-hour chemistry
class. Are those the same?
So like harmonizing data across
a bunch of universities was
insanely complicated. But
it delved really deeply into
the unit of analysis of
the individual course.
And then, of course,
you can go even lower.
What about the section?
What about the instructor?
And we
are here to support efforts
like that, as well--
which, by the way, is why
this job is so epically fun, because
for three weeks, you're
talking about bookstore prices.
And then you're trying
to figure out why
courses that have just a
midterm and a final are
different from courses that have a
variety of assessments along the way.
So--
I don't know. That was a
long answer. But the gist is,
we live where we live,
organizationally.
But we have touch points
across the university.
And if we didn't,
we wouldn't have
as good of an ability to answer
the really hard questions,
where those two things land
in exactly the same spot.
A student might not be
successful because they might
have basic-needs problems.
They might need
additional financial aid.
They might not have
a sense of belonging.
They might not be
engaged in a community.
They might also just really
not be that good at math,
and need help with that. And
all of that is part of the
interconnected
"supply chain."
- That's great. Thank you.
It sounds like such a
really fascinating place to
work with, so much variety
of problems and teams and people--
juggling a ton. But it
sounds really, really neat. Thanks.
- Yeah, of course.
It's completely wild.
But it is fun. It's an
incredible amount of fun,
definitely.
RACHAEL DEMSPEY: Yeah,
it's really interesting to hear
about the different variety of
problems you get to work on.
I think, when we were
talking a bit earlier, Brad,
you mentioned that
there aren't that
many schools, today,
that have a chief data officer.
And I was wondering, for schools
who are maybe in that spot
of starting out, or starting
this role of chief data
officer, if you have
any tips to share them.
- Yeah,
I get this question
pretty often.
And
so I'm going to get my
numbers a little bit wrong.
But there's roughly 4,000
or 5,000 institutions in the
United States that
receive Title IV funding.
Maybe it's actually probably
a little bit higher.
But that's everything,
from the California Barber
College to Stanford.
And that's basically--
Title IV funding means
that they're eligible for Federal
Student Loans or--
well, that's probably it.
They're probably in the
Higher Education Act,
which Congress
never reauthorizes.
So we're always under
20-year-old rules.
But there's thousands and
thousands and thousands of
universities. And I'll just get
on my soapbox for four seconds,
to say, remember that number
the next time you read, in
The New
York Times, or
The Wall
Street Journal,
or The Washington
Post, that it's so
hard to get into college.
It's not.
We have so many choices.
And most schools admit most
students. So I always
like to just tell people,
the national media does not
paint a very good picture of
the higher-ed landscape at all.
Off the soapbox, of those,
from what I understand,
there's probably
50 or so chief data officers
or fewer people with that title.
There is a very traditional
function, in higher ed,
called institutional
research, which
reports out all the numbers
to the federal government.
And they typically
do this kind of work.
So
I'm not trying to
pick on you, Lisa. But
at Macalester, in Saint Paul,
they actually have a
really amazing institutional research
office that's run by
really cool people.
But if you've worked in higher
ed, you've, at some point,
bumped into your IR group.
If you want to know
anything about a university,
these data are
publicly available.
And so there's someone who
submits all of those data.
And it's usually IR.
But what's happening
more and more is,
institutions are realizing
that their data is this core,
institutional asset,
and that the more value that
can be gotten out of those data,
the better the institution can do
and the better that they can
support students.
There's also a growing sort
of sense that with the regulatory
framework and with compliance
frameworks and with the need
for data governance and with
the need for more standardized
policies around
data, that-- oh,
look we have an IPEDS
key holder. Look at that. Cool.
Nice to see you, George--
but
the conversation around, how
do we broadly manage our data,
is something that a chief
data officer should be responsible for.
And I wouldn't say it's like
a thing. But I'd say that,
probably, once a month,
some university reaches out to
me on LinkedIn and is like,
should we have a chief
data officer? What does that mean?
What does the construct
look like in higher ed?
And just
like it was a growing trend
in industry, probably,
over the last 10 years, it's
now catching up in higher ed.
And yes, there's a
little bit of a chat.
IPEDS is the Integrated
Postsecondary Education Data System.
If you want to know
the number of enrolled
Asian students at the
University of Texas, Paso,
it's all in there. And
it's publicly available.
- Thank you.
BRAD WEINER: Yep.
- I always do a double
check on acronyms.
BRAD WEINER: Yep.
RACHAEL DEMSPEY: [? Deepsha, ?]
I see you had a
question in the chat.
Do you want to
jump in here next?
- Thanks, Rachael. If
I get a cough attack,
I might hand it back to
you, to complete the question, but--
- I'll be ready.
- This has been
really fascinating,
to learn about the setting
of university and the kind of
problems that you have.
I'm a data scientist
at Microsoft. And usually,
in a business setting,
I know the challenge that
you spoke of is someone actually
taking the action on the
analysis you're doing, is a
really big challenge.
And so on here, a lot of
times, we don't pick up analysis that
could be interesting because
we don't have the identified
stakeholders that would
actually take the action,
or willing to take the action.
But it's also chicken and egg.
If they don't see the analysis,
they don't know what possible
action they could take.
So how do you overcome
that challenge?
How do you pick out the
projects? How do you prioritize them,
considering you mentioned such
a vast variety of projects
you're able to take?
- Yeah, I would say--
carefully and imperfectly.
And I think it's-- one
of the coolest things--
and I have to give a hat tip
to Posit and to Rachael--
one of the coolest things about
getting in a room like this is
realizing that we all
have the same challenges.
I always had this idea,
like, oh, you work at Amazon,
you work at Microsoft. They've
solved everything. Right?
And I've worked in higher ed.
This place-- it's
been here since 1876.
It's not going anywhere
soon. But it's certainly
decentralized and
compartmentalized and has those
same type of
organizational challenges.
And I'm not bagging on CU.
I'm bagging on--
I'm not even bagging on.
I'm describing the reality of
being in a university environment.
And I would say that
mostly, we take on projects in
what will ostensibly have the largest
potential impact for students or
for what we're trying to do.
There's also a little bit of
a conversation that I think I've
thought deeply about,
[? Deepsha, ?] which is,
what is within your
span of control?
And sometimes it's not-- and
this might come across as
the easy road out. But
it's like, what are things that
we could directly
impact or influence?
And then there are
also times where
the decision is made
in ways that I refer to as,
you're bringing water to
the desert, where occasionally,
there are people that have
nothing. They are just totally
out in the open. And
so on that dimension,
of what's easy for us versus
what's valuable to them,
is such in the sweet spot
because this simplest,
most basic thing--
it's like someone's just
been asking forever,
all I need is this one thing and
to be able to get at it, routinely.
And you're like,
hold my beer. Let's focus
the sprint. Let's focus the
cycles on that one thing.
And those tend to be the
situations where people come
back and they're like,
thank you so, so much.
We just needed
this one dashboard.
So I would say, if
there's a thing that's easy for
you and high value to someone
else, that's worthwhile.
If there's something
where you really feel like
it's totally within your
galaxy to be like, hey,
we had this finding,
that finding suggests we
shouldn't do this again,
you're the person who's
directly responsible for that,
don't do that again, and
that's right within your
sort of frame of reference
or within your span of control--
And then, of course,
as someone who
just-- in case you can't
tell, I'm a wacky guy.
I really value fun and joy and
being a little bit weird,
which I think is OK, and that
one tiny corner of your
whole portfolio should just be that
random thing that seems like it's
going to be a ton of fun
to work on because those are
the kinds of things that keep
people engaged.
And a lot of times, it
isn't fun in some whimsical way.
But it's just new, like
this bookstore thing.
That was hard work. It
was a complicated problem.
But it was probably
five weeks of work,
it was time boxed. And
it was that one thing.
And then we passed it
on. And we're like, oh,
that was cool.
We got to run tens of thousands
of simulations on student
opt-out behavior.
Now back to our regularly
scheduled program.
And we can focus on
the core stuff again.
So is that helpful?
- No, it definitely
is. And it's
great to see how that
value-to-effort constant
measurement has to be done
in almost any setting.
It's common and it's constant.
So thank you so
much for sharing.
-
And you did ask another
question about how do you
convince people
to use the data.
And that is, I think--
it just takes time. And it
takes trust. And it takes effort. And
it's also a recognition that it
is not a linear path of, we're
getting better and
better and better,
and every single time
there's more trust.
You go from step one to
step two, and that's great,
and step two to step
three, and that's great.
And then people start
coming to you more.
And then you totally botch something.
And you're back to step
one because the thing went
sideways. And so
I like to think that
organizations are
more resilient than we think
they are and that mistakes are
less damaging than we think
they are, in most cases.
And so
people shouldn't be too hard
on themselves. If you're like,
we found this thing, and
then people go, oh, that's cool,
right on, we're still going to
do this other thing, and you're like,
but you might not want to
do that because the data say this--
And I will say that higher
ed is especially prone to folklore and
to
people believing that their
experience is outweighing data.
That's changing a lot.
But one of the most fun
parts about working in higher ed--
and this is one of the things that
I was talking to Rachael about-- is that
if you work in some industries,
finding the inefficiencies is really
hard because all of the
inefficiencies have already been found.
And in higher ed, they're
all over the place.
So it's pretty cool.
But to give you guys a
quick story about folklore,
has anyone ever heard the myth
that students choose which
college they're going to go to
based on the weather on the day
that they visit campus? Has
anyone ever been down that one?
- I have.
BRAD WEINER: Someone has?
[INAUDIBLE] has. I really wanted
to go to School X.
But it was rainy and terrible.
There's no way I'm going there.
So
it's maybe a little bit
of an admissions joke.
But there is some
mythology around that.
I happen to used to work at
the University of Minnesota.
Minnesota has famously
great weather.
And I tested that assumption. And
it turns out to be false.
And that included pulling
hour-by-hour data--
weather data-- for
every single day,
going back years
and years and years,
and matching that up with
when students visited.
But to make it even
more interesting--
I know I'm talking to
a bunch of data people.
So you're all going to be
like, how did you do that?
I actually calculated,
not the weather on campus,
but I calculated the delta
of the weather on campus from
where they came because I'm
imagining someone from Southern
California being like, wow,
this is a shocking difference.
And I modeled that
in every possible
way. It was full-on
P-hacking? data torture.
And I couldn't find anything
to support that assumption.
So the next time you
hear that one, college admissions people,
I tested it in truly one
of the worst climates,
or the most extreme climates,
in America. And it's not true.
- That it's such an
interesting analysis. I absolutely love it.
BRAD WEINER: Thank you for
your great question, [? Deepsha. ?]
- Thank you.
I see Michael had asked
a question in the chat.
And there's stars so I'm
going to read it. But it was,
"Brad, do you have any
experiences or stories in using
data science techniques
to attempt to measure the
effectiveness of CU's strategic
communication efforts,
particularly in terms
of things like"-- well,
I guess this past example
could tie to this-- but,
"particularly in terms
of things like recruiting
effectiveness or public
sentiment to university
outreach efforts?"
I'll copy the question over
into the chat again, too.
- Yeah, that's a
great question.
We have a lot of
connections with what, at universities, is
called enrollment management.
And they ask questions
like that all the time.
And
I don't want to go too much
into the details because
it's
complicated to tease out.
But that is a really common set
of questions, that are asked, which is,
really, what is the
effectiveness of anything?
What is the effectiveness
of a virtual visit versus an
on-campus visit? What
is the effectiveness of
an email versus a
paper mailing? And those
are the types of things
that are routinely asked, and that
if you work at an
organization that does sort of marketing
work or does communications work,
those are also, I think,
some of the highest-value
conversations to have in
data-science land
because so often,
what we do is very tough to
append a specific cost or a specific
ROI to.
And so there are things like
that, where you're like, look, we
sent out this mailer. Did
it work or did it not?
We sent out this
email communication. Did
it work or did it not?
Or what was the effect of that?
Or what was the effect of
that on different students?
And
email is basically
free. So it's an
arcane and not very
important research question.
But there are questions of
this whole combination of
communications. What do those do?
And if they are found to
have limited impact, then
it's very-- it's easy,
or it tends to be easy,
to make that argument, of,
you really should pivot these
dollars to something else.
And
enrollment management
is becoming increasingly
scientific. It really is.
There's a guy whose
name is Brock Tibert.
He's going to be mad at
me, that I mentioned his name.
But he thinks of it as a
science, enrollment science,
because what you
have are, you have
millions of high
school graduates.
And you need to land a class
that is big enough to--
it needs to be big enough
to support your operations.
It needs to be the right size.
But you also need to
have that across different majors and
different colleges and
different programs.
And you need balance across
all these different things.
So
if you Google the concept
of enrollment management or
enrollment science,
you'll find a bazillion papers out
there on how this happens. And
it starts with
millions and millions and
millions of people, whose
name gets entered into
a database, basically.
And
this is also a
really fascinating conversation, now, because
COVID had a dramatic effect
on this entire industry.
One of the big things was
that many, many,
many more schools are now no
longer requiring the SAT or the ACT.
And in so doing,
the SAT and ACT were the
primary source of a lot of
these names. And so even
getting the marketing apparatus
going around student enrollment is
a different story than it
was even three to
five years ago.
But the short answer is yes.
And you can find all kinds
of resources and information
online about that.
You can also look
me up on LinkedIn.
And I used to work at a startup
that did that very thing,
which was email
marketing campaigns to
prospective college students.
And we had a ton of research
and information on how to do that well.
- I'll share your LinkedIn in
the chat, here, in a second too.
- And I'm sorry if sometimes I
have to be vague. I probably-- I
don't want to get myself in
hot water by sharing results that
are probably not shareable.
- That's OK. We're
used to that.
- At least it's not
the sports people.
I'm a sports analytics person.
We did a thing and
it made us win.
Sorry. I can't say anymore.
- Yeah, that's a hard one.
Scott, I see you
had asked a question earlier.
I think it was about Connect,
if you want to jump in.
SCOTT: Yeah, sure.
No, I appreciate this conversation.
So I'm also in the
higher-ed, data-analytics, and IR
world, over at Georgetown.
I resonate with a lot
of comments about Tableau and thisspace
and Power BI and everything
around it, Looker, you name it.
But curious-- I think I have
found a team of folks
who is really curious,
and sees an enormous amount
of potential in the open source
space in the orbit of R
and Python and that sort of thing,
and was curious whether you
have a Connect server up and
going, whether you're working
with it in a
production fashion,
or whether you've
thought about it or
were headed in that direction?
And it isn't as common in
IR as I might have thought.
So yeah,
just curious about whether
you've thought in that space.
- We have. And I think
that it is certainly
a direction we'd be interested
in pursuing, is going into
open-source
visualization tools.
We do have kind of an
inter-operable, multilingual
data science team.
And by the way, this is only
on the administrative side.
There are, of course,
hundreds of academic units
out there, Scott, as you know.
Who knows if the Physics
department has a massive server
on there, deploying everything.
Who knows? Very possible.
Actually,
to give you a sense
of how decentralized higher ed is,
it was easier for me to
ask Rachael, which other people on
CU's campus were using Posit,
rather than finding out myself.
So that's the world
that we're in.
RACHAEL DEMSPEY: Anybody wants to
know, they can always ask
me, for your own organizations.
- So
I honestly think that,
as powerful and as great
as those tools are,
we still haven't exactly figured
out how to make that happen.
And some of that is
tradition and sort of common
use of existing tools.
And then some of that
is the deployment question, which is--
one of the biggest
complaints you get,
when you're working in
a big organization, is,
please don't give me
something else to log into.
My bookmark bar is
already 900 things.
But Scott, I
would think that if
you have the appetite to build
it-- and then, of course,
there's the cost
structure around it, where
deploying something
in Posit isn't free.
But it's definitely
cheaper than other options.
But I would love to
connect and hear what
your journey is like.
We do have a couple of
people who've build stuff in Shiny.
But then we go, well,
some end user wants to
touch that and interact with it.
And that end user is almost
certainly not going to have the
skills to even like fire up
an IDE and run the framework.
So we're probably in
early days on that.
But I think what's probably a
more likely path is that we would,
at least to start--
and this is all just me
brainstorming in front of 127 people
on a high wire-- would be
that we would use some of the
semantic HTML frameworks that
come from open-source tools.
So we would deploy using
something like Flex dashboard or something
like-- oh, my gosh, why is
my brain falling out of my ear--
Highchart, which is free
use, for academic institutions,
to just deploy HTML web pages
and put those out there.
I think that would
be our gateway
into a full deployment
of something like Shiny.
- Yeah, thanks so much. And
I may ping you later because
again, we're at the front
end of this, and I think,
on one hand, see a lot
of potential, but also,
there's just a lot of
inertia elsewhere in the organization,
as you well know and as
we've already talked about this morning.
- Yeah, it's a hard problem,
to move people into a
new technical space. But Scott,
I could share some other paths
we're going down as well,
which are pretty cool.
- Yeah, great, thanks.
BRAD WEINER: Yep.
- I see Peter, you had a
follow up question. I think it was,
maybe, on the weather use
case. But I'm not sure.
Do you want to jump in, here?
PETER: Oh, sure. I was just
wondering if your test,
for that question, was looking
at all of the institutions that
they were applying to, or if you
were only able to look at one.
- Oh, man, if
we had comparative data across
a bunch of institutions,
that would be amazing.
But it was just for
my single institution.
And so yes,
I should be a much better
data scientist and put a bunch of
asterisks at the end
of that description.
That finding was limited
and localized and not generalizable
to any institution,
beyond the single one that
I did the analysis on--
over the time period
that I did it on,
in the population
that I did it on.
So fully
great question.
Peter--
because we have a bunch of
compliance rules-- there's a
federal law, called FERPA,
which is the Federal Education
Records Protection Act--
there's a lot of stuff
that we can't share. And so
getting a
multi-institution-level data
set, at the unit of
analysis of student-level records, is
really, really,
really complicated.
And
institutions are just
very reluctant to share,
not necessarily--
We're very good at sharing--
so Scott just asked that question.
And I have every confidence--
Patrick just asked the
question-- that IR are people,
or Institutional Analytics people-- you
all can call me up.
And one of the best parts about
higher ed is we all have the
same mission. We are
nominally in competition.
But we're really trying to just
provide an economic ladder,
provide research, and make
the world a little
bit better of a place.
So we're widely collaborative. People
can call up and go, hey,
how did you do this?
And I will just straight
up tell people how that worked.
But the data sharing,
the ability to do
those multi-institutional analyses, is
quite challenging
in a lot of cases.
But one of the things
we're actually working on, here at
CU, is following after
the health care industry,
we are starting to develop
fully synthetic data sets that
will allow us to do that.
And I don't know many
institutions that are doing
that. But I'm really excited
for a future where we could
create synthetic data sets
that mirror this, essentially, the
distributions that exist
in a real data set,
but don't fall under the
data privacy and data protections
of federal law.
But great question, Peter.
I hope I answered
that sufficiently.
- Thank you.
AJ, I see you had just asked
a question in the chat.
Do you want to
jump in here next?
AJ: Yeah. Sorry if I
missed it, maybe, earlier,
if you mentioned it already.
But did your company start off
with having a data office? Or
if not, what sort of
efforts it took to
create your role? Because
today, a lot of big-- even
big companies sit on piles of data.
But data is something just
that's lumped under IT, normally.
Just wondering
your take on that.
- Yeah,
so I haven't been here,
at CU, for too, too long.
So the history is, maybe,
a little bit murky. But
pretty much every university
has had an office,
that's typically
called institutional Research,
that has focused on these
analytic questions, and then, of course,
reporting to the various
agencies that require reporting.
So here in Colorado,
we have a bunch of requirements that
we report to the state of Colorado.
We have a bunch of connections
with the city of Boulder,
to make sure that
we're integrated there.
We have a bunch of
connections with
the federal government
because of Title IV funding,
because of research funding.
So we have a lot of
data needs, to make
sure that we are being
in compliance and that we're
being as effective as possible.
So the tradition of having a data
office in higher ed goes way back,
decades and decades
and decades.
But as the appetite
for data has grown,
and as the appetite for
people to make smarter decisions and
more data-informed
decisions has grown,
these data conversations have gotten
bigger and bigger and bigger.
So do you have someone
who's there to deploy and analyze
surveys? Do you have
somebody who is there
to do research on how
faculty are performing,
to have to understand
how students are performing,
to really think through,
not just how many questions,
but what is the relationship
between x and y questions?
And then finally, the third
layer of that is just,
how do we make the best use
of our data in a secure and a
systematic way? How do we
democratize it? How do we scale
it? How do we govern it.
And so I would say that every
university, no matter
how big or small,
the smallest community
college anywhere,
probably has some--
even if it's one person--
some person who's
doing analytic work.
But I think having
a centralized, systematic, networked
office, that's responsible
for thinking about data as an
asset, is probably
a growing trend.
But I went to a Gartner
thing a year or two ago.
And they had a little higher-ed
table. And it was like, oh,
so you're the 6.
But I imagine that you
go a year from now,
and there will be 12. And
I imagine you go a year from
then, there will be 40. And
higher ed is often
last to the party.
But we
track the trends that go on
in industry, quite often.
- Thank you.
As we-- oh, sorry--
AJ: Oh, no, I was just
saying thank you. Thank you.
BRAD WEINER: Of course.
- Thank you all for
the great questions too. As we
get to the top of the hour,
here, if there's
anything I missed,
feel free to raise your
hand, here on Zoom,
so I can see it as well,
and can call you in here.
But Brad, one
question-- actually,
one of my colleagues
had asked this earlier.
But they mentioned they
saw something online,
that you host a community of
practice event, and I was just
curious to learn how that came
together and how you publicized it.
- Yeah, that's a
great question. So
there was an online
community of practice.
There was a Zoom meeting
when I first joined CU.
And
what we found-- and I think
this gets back, a little bit,
to [? Deepsha's ?]
question, which is,
how do you get people to be in
the experience?
And
the College of Engineering
has analysts. And
all these places have analysts.
And they all have people
who are working on similar
problems. And so the
better we are able to
coordinate everybody and the
better we're able to work
with everybody,
the better we do.
So we built out this
data community practice.
And it was a Zoom thing.
And we invited some guests.
And I haven't looked through
the whole list, here.
But I may have hit some of you
up to be a guest at some point.
I know one person,
in particular.
But anyway,
we'd have people come in
and talk about data governance or
master data management.
Or we'd have people come in
and talk about different things. And
the idea surfaced of,
we're all tired of staring at
each other on Zoom, a little bit.
This is amazing because you're
all distributed all over the
world. But we
have a need to build
this community.
And so we decided to have
an event. And we actually,
jokingly-- I name
things so stupidly.
The biggest problem in computer
science is naming things.
It's why I'm never going
to be a computer scientist because
I'm terrible at naming things.
But we straight-up
went with like IRL.
We're going to have a data
community practice conference in real life.
And let's all get into
the room together.
And let's focus on a
couple of things. One,
we wanted to do some
actual technical training and provide
that value to our campus.
So we had one training session
that was in R in the tidyverse.
And we had another one
that was in Tableau.
And it was just a chance
to take some real experts in that
and lift a bunch of
boats all at once.
And then we had some
broader conversations,
including a keynote
speaker, who spoke
about the need to think
about data in more equitable ways.
We are constantly having
this conversation about-- these
important conversations
around diversity and equity,
and around racism
and anti-racism.
And
believe it or not, if
you haven't spent time thinking
about it, the way you collect
data, the way you capture data,
the way you count
people matters.
And so we brought in someone
who is an expert in this--
his name is Carson Byrd.
We brought him in
from the University of Michigan--
to really talk to everybody
and to have a thought-provoking
conversation around the ways
that data may or may not
reflect the communities that
we're trying to represent.
And then we also gave
people the opportunity to do some
lightning talks, which
were absolutely amazing, just--
we invited people from around campus
to basically say, for 15 minutes,
you have the opportunity to talk
about a problem that is vexing you.
And
I cannot tell you
enough how cool it was--
and I would recommend it to
any of your organizations--
to not only stand
up a community of practice,
and just get people
together and say, hey,
what are you working on,
what problems do you have,
but to occasionally do your best
to try and get everybody together,
in
a meaningful way, because people walked
out of that, in my view,
not only technically better,
but with the ability to sit
down and eat lunch with that
person who sits across campus and
is working on the same thing.
So the Zoom thing came together
before me. But we were like,
you know what? Let's get off
Zoom for a day and a half.
And it was
a ton of fun. Highly recommend.
- I love that. I love
anything to do with community.
That sounds awesome. OK. We
have a few minutes, here.
So I might just rapid
the remaining questions to you.
BRAD WEINER: All right,
I'll see if I can do
them in 20 seconds.
Let's see how many
we can get through.
- [? Siring ?] asked,
"have you done any analysis
of the chances of a student
successfully finishing a course
or failing out?"
- Yeah, that's a really,
really common type of analysis
that happens, in higher ed,
is trying to estimate
a student's likelihood. But
again, we're not here to
filter people out or
to make people feel--
there isn't some channel for that.
What it allows us to do
is, it allows us to
focus our resources,
like any predictive model,
on the students that might
need additional help.
So if we can estimate that
a student might not be successful
in a particular class, it
isn't, don't take that class.
It's, what support can we give
you so that you are successful.
- Thank you. And I think
you answered this one in the chat.
But is there a likelihood
of colleges to move to
AWS or Azure completely?
- Yeah.
Hang out in my email for a
day and you'll see that higher ed--
it's a massive industry.
There are thousands of universities.
And yes, there are institutions
that have fully gone into
a variety of cloud environments
for a variety of reasons. So
no doubt.
- Well-- and I think, maybe,
one last question that I
missed, was, you talked
about synthetic data sets.
Do you have any packages
you could recommend, or approaches?
- I would need to
get back to you.
I think that we're
building those in Python.
And my Python chops are
a little bit weaker.
So I could find out what
we're using. And yes.
I
also-- I forgot to drop
my favorite fun fact,
which is that IPython
was a side project of a
grad student at CU Boulder in the
early 2000s. So
Fernando Perez is a physicist,
and realized there wasn't
an interactive way to touch
Python. And so there's some lab
around here in which I Python,
and subsequently Jupyter,
were born. So
depending on your view of
Jupyter notebooks,
either you're
welcome or I'm sorry.
- Well, thank you
so much, Brad.
I think that we got through
most, if not all, of the
questions. But if there's
anything you missed,
and anybody wants to send it my way,
I can share it with Brad, as well.
But it was a pleasure getting
to learn from you and hear
about all the
different projects
you're working on across
the university. This was awesome.
- Thank you very much,
everyone. Thanks for your time.
And thanks, Rachael and Posit,
for having me. And if anyone
has questions, you can
find me in all
the normal spaces.
- Sounds great.
Thanks, everybody.